Bây giờ tại hồi nghĩ thường định khí hậu toàn cầu và làm brazin,
nơi sẽ đang cai cốt và mười tình emu mười đến Hà Mí Mô tâm emu.
Phó tụ tưởng Trung Quốc ông định tiếp tưởng Kêu Gọc các cú gà rất bỏ giọc cảnh thương mạc
đang tìm hạm tên trình trên đổi nắng lộ xanh toàn cầu.
Đông thời tục dục cân lất phát triển thực hiện miếm cảm két tại chính và các giảng khí thải.
Ông định nhấn mạnh, cần tục đời chủ miệch đào phương thứ chất,
tăng cường hợp tác của tế trong công nghệ xanh và nắng lực tại tạo.
Cung như bảo đảm giọng trải tự gió của cá sản phẩm thân thiệp với mù trường theo tình họ sả,
bất kinh sẽ sản hợp tác với các đổi tác kinh chỉ phát triển xanh và phát thải thấp.
Phó tụ tưởng Trung Quốc lòng thời kêu gọc các nên kinh tế phát triển,
làm gương trước nhận vụ giảng có thể và tăng hỗ trợ đại chính,
công nghệ cho các nước nhau, đông thời là đối tượng chữ ngoài hưởng nặng nãy nhất của mình ở khi hậu.
Trung Quốc hiện là của gia có sản lượng nặng lượng tại tạo lượng nhất thế giới.
Chủ tịch tập cắt mình dần công bố mù tiêu giảng bây giờ để mời phần chăm lượng và thải khi nhắc kính tòa nền kích tế,
cho tởi năm 2018. Đông thời năng tị trọng năng lượng phía hòa thách,
lê hơn 8 mệt phần chăm tổng têu thủ của gia.